it's the biggest shake-up in president
zielinski's leadership team since the
start of the war Irina vendictova was
the prosecutor General Ivan balakov
headed the internal security agency both
have been suspended President zielinski
says 651 cases of treason people working
with the Russians are being investigated
in their offices and both could face
being fired by Parliament
such an array of crimes against the
foundations of the state's national
security and the links recorded between
Ukrainian security Force officials and
Russian special services raises very
serious questions about their respective
leaders each of these questions will
receive a proper response today I've
taken the decision to dismiss the
general prosecutor and the head of the
Ukrainian Security Service there's no
suggestion that either figure was
actively working against Ukraine instead
this is more a question of
accountability a failure of leadership
in their respective departments
bakinov was a childhood friend of the
president he was involved in the
entertainment industry and
disappointment to run internal security
was a surprise when the Russians moved
into Kirsten early in the war that was
seen as a huge intelligence failure by
his Department
over the weekend dozens attended the
funeral of a four-year-old killed in the
fighting Lisa dimitriva died when
Rockets hit Venezia last week her body
was found in the rubble she is the
latest child victim of a war which
according to new figures from the United
Nations has claimed more than 5020
civilian lives 300 of them children and
seen more than
6520 people wounded this as towns and
cities across the southern east walk up
to the sound of War moving into its 21st
week Alan Fisher Al Jazeera Kiev or Doug
Klein is from the Atlantic council's
Eurasia Center he says zielinski must
act quickly to find replacements for the
two suspended officials
so I do think that these are significant
and the big thing that observers and
experts are going to be watching for is
who comes next zelenski has appointed an
acting prosecutor general to replace
benedictiva is not yet appointed uh
somebody to replace Ukraine's top uh
intelligence and security Chief during
wartime that is an essential role uh so
that that's the big thing that experts
are going to be watching for who comes
next the other thing here is that while
a reason wasn't given by president
zielinski for why he fired uh the
prosecutor General he said that these
security breaches were the big reason
why he lost confidence in his security
Chief uh just today Ukraine's sbu head
for uh Crimea was arrested on charges of
high treason and passing intelligence to
Russians he is one of many high
officials in the intelligence Services
who have been charged with these uh uh
charges of collaborating with the
Invaders one of the big things that uh
you know prosecutor General benedictova
was mired in for much of her term was
failing to uh properly reform her uh her
uh office and allowing and sabotaging
investigations into bribery cases uh and
and failing to properly do her uh
executor duties uh so for the
prosecution of war crimes that is one of
the top priorities for ukrainians and
it's something that the International
Community has taken very serious
interest in aiding them with so uh
whoever comes next uh the International
Community is going to be trying to work
with them very closely to make sure that
there's no hiccup uh in making sure that
these crimes are prosecuted